[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de Parlement Hebdo on revient
comme d'habitude sur les séquences
marquantes de la semaine politique et
parlementaire dominé bien sûr par le
projet de loi immigration et pour la
dernière émission de cette année 2023
nous accueillons Yan Chantrel bonjour
bonjour vous êtes sénateur socialiste
des Français établis hors de France et
on reviendra donc avec notre invité sur
les nouveaux rapports de force politique
après l'adoption de la loi immigration
elle a été votée avec les voies de la
droite et celle du rassemblement
national mais pas par toute la majorité
l'exécutif se défend de toute crise
politique malgré la démission d'un
ministre et on verra ce que contient
cette nouvelle loi immigration
instauration de quota prestation sociale
sous conditions fin du droit du sol
automatique plusieurs dispositions
ajoutées par la droite sénatoriale
change profondément le droit des
étrangers mais pas si vite certaines
dispositions pourraient être retoquées
par le Conseil constitutionnel au nom du
principe d'égalité ou parce qu'elles
n'ont rien à faire dans la loi les Sages
ont un mois pour se
prononcer l'Assemblée nationale a donc
adopté mardi le projet de loi
immigration issue de la commission mixte
paritaire un vote qui a divisé la
majorité présidentielle indigné la
gauche et réjoui les républicains et le
rassemblement national le tout vous est
raconté par thbao hoc pour 349 contre
186 l'Assemblée nationale a adopté la
loi immigration votée mardi où
l'épilogue d'une séquence politique qui
va laisser des traces premier pilier
estbranlé la majorité sur ce texte mon
groupe a d'emblé désigné collectivement
ces lignes rouges celles-ci ont été
respecté avec 189 votes pour 27 contre
et 32 abstentions c'est pourtant près
d'un/4 des députés de la majorité qui a
refusé de soutenir le texte issu de la
CMP une fracture qui aurait pu être plus
profonde encore si le gouvernement
n'avait pas annoncé qu'il exclurait les
voix du rassemblement national du
résultat il n'y aura pas de texte s'il
n'y a pas de majorité sans le
rassemblement national ça s'appelle le
sens de l'honneur un rassemblement
national qui clame pourtant sa victoire
un non sens selon le gouvernement vos
sénateurs eren ont voté contre le texte
du Sénat voilà un mois désormais c'est
le texte du Sénat moin 15 mesures
symboliques et vous votez pour pour qui
vous nous prenez
on peut tout de même se réjouir d'
victoire même idéologique du
rassemblement national puisque est
inscrit maintenant dans cette loi la
priorité nationale autrec à revendiqué
sa victoire la droite les républicains
ont été au centre des négociations avec
l'exécutif comme il le souhaitait c'est
finalement une version proche de celle
adoptée au Sénat par leur majorité qui a
été voté un nouveau chemin est ouvert il
a été ouvert très clairement par les
républicains nous avions dit que nous
voulions ce texte il est là quant à la
gauche frontalement opposé au texte et à
l'origine de la motion de rejet voté le
11 décembre elle aura en vain appelé la
majorité à renoncer tout ce que vous
aviez tenu pour des lignes rouges a été
allègrement transgressé et pour
rapprocher franchissez désormais des
lignes bleu marines des concessions qui
aux yeux des opposants à la loi auront
marqué des compromissions
indélébil Yann chanrel 25 % des députés
de la majorité donc députés du inclu
n'ont pas voté la loi immigration est-ce
que pour vous c'est la fin du matronisme
tel qu'il existe jusque- là oui euh
c'est la fin du en même temps faut voir
aussi que qu'est-ce que c'est le
macronisme avant tout le seul mandat
réel qu'a le président de la République
à partir du moment qu'il a été élu c'est
pour faire barrage à l'extrême droite et
là il en reprend finalement le programme
historique du rassemblement national du
Front national en quelque sorte à
travers ces différentes mesures qui ont
été mises dedans dont la déchéance de
nationalité dont le président de la
République lui-même avait combattu en
2016 et il perd donc un/4 un/art de sa
majorité gaeement voilà il perd un/4 de
de sa majorité donc qui se rétrécit de
plus en plus il avait déjà un
gouvernement minoritaire donc en fait on
a l'impression déjà d'être dans un fin
de règne une sorte de fin de règne alors
qu'il y a déjà plus il a encore plus de
3 ans de de mandat devant nous donc en
fait quand est-ce que ça va s'arrêter
c'est un peu ça quand est-ce qu'il va
continuer à aller dans un puissant fond
et surtout ce que ça montre qu'est-ce
que c'est que le macronisme finalement
il y a pas de colonne vertébrale il y a
rien c'est juste de l'opportunisme
politique c'estàd qu'il y a des
personnes au sein de ce gouvernement qui
elles-mêmes se disent avoir appartenu à
une époque à la gauche en quelque sorte
qui accepte une loi que je qualifie de
célérate de ce typelà et qui rest donc
et qui l'ont voté donc vous dites oui
qui qui l'ont voté et qui restent en
poste je pense que quand on a réellement
des convictions humanistes qu'on
considère que là il y a un cap qui a été
franchi ce 19 décembre il a il y a
réellement un cap qui a été franchi de
la part du gouvernement et du président
de la République on on va dans un
puissant fond vers l'extrême droite et
ça c'est très dangereux et c'est pour ça
que nous-même à travers les syndicats
l'ensemble des partis de gauche et des
syndicats on appelle au président de la
République de renoncer justement à cette
loi qui a été adopter de la retirer mais
justement le président de la République
qui a été interviewé cette semaine
estime que ce texte immigration c'est un
bouclier je cite he qui permet de mieux
lutter contre le rassemblement national
est-ce qu'un texte ferme sur
l'immigration ça peut faire baisser le
RN alors moi je pense pas ce qui fait
baisser le RN c'est de reprendre sa
politique parce que les propositions du
rassemblement national n'apaisent pas
notre pays elle le divisent elle le
Clive ce qu'on souhaite nous aussi à
gauche c'est favoriser l'intégration ce
qui était aussi dans l'intitulé de ce
texte à la base c'était de favoriser
également l'intégration et effectivement
il faut la favoriser au maximum il y a
pas une seule des dispositions qui sont
prises qui la favorise au contraire
c'est l'inverse qui va se produire quand
vous empêchez le regroupement familial
je suis désolé vous ne favorisez pas
l'intégration vous favorisez
l'intégration des personnes quands ont
la possibilité d'être avec leurs proches
ça ça facilite leur intégration alors le
gouvernement Martelle le contraire
pourtantabth B dit il y a quand même des
mesures pour mieux intégrer alors on les
cherche on les a cherché à l'ou pas de
français honnêtement il a il y a pas
grandchose VO rien du tout c'est risible
et toutes les mesur de français c'est
pas suffisant c'est pas les cours de
français c'est une bonne chose pour
faciliter l'intégration effectivement
mais ça reste pinups c'est pas
grand-chose c'est rien par contre les
mesures qui ont été prises dont je vous
parle il y a la déchéance de nationalité
la restriction du regroupement familial
alors après l'histoire de la caution
pour les étudiants étrangers une
véritable catastrophe pour le
rayonnement de notre pays même je pense
que ce texte en fait c'est un texte
d'affaiblissement en plus de notre pays
par rapport à on n'est pas sur une île
par rapport à l'étranger alors vous
dites un cap a été franchi ce 19
décembre on est dans une crise politique
pourtant Yan chentrrel un seul ministre
a
démissionné oui ben en tout cas je salue
justement son courage parce qu'il y a
quand même un ministre qui a été courage
qui qui a démissionné en lien avec ses
valeurs en lien aussi parce que
contrairement à ce que dit le le
gouvernement également l'ame c'est la
prochaine chose qui est visée par par le
gouvernement il a eu un engagement il y
a une lettre de de la première ministre
également pour pouvoir faire voter
justement la droite et l'extrême droite
leur texte donc donc il a il a
démissionné c'est très bien je sais
qu'il y a la ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur qui a également proposé sa
démission et on n pas besoin de la
proposer quand c'est pas en accord no
valeur on n pas besoin de demander
l'autorisation on démissionne et je
pense qu'elle aurait raison de
démissionner mais mais clairement
au-delà des des simples démissions c'est
le cap politique c'est-à-dire qu'il y a
un changement de cap politique qui est à
droite toute qui est nocive pour notre
pays qui est très dangereuse et quelque
part on demande au gouvernement et au
président de la République de se
ressaisir Yan Chantrel est-ce que les
députés de gauche ont aussi une
responsabilité en ayant voté il y a 10
jours la motion de rejet de ce texte
immigration à l'Assemblée nationale
c'est-à-dire qu'il n'y a pas eu de débat
à l'Assemblée que du coup c'est le texte
plus dur de la droite sénatoriale qui a
été imposé à la majorité est-ce que la
gauche a une responsabilité alors il
faut pas inverser les responsabilités la
gauche est contre ce texte donc elle a
acté le fait qu'elle y était contre elle
a adopté une motion de Roget ça fait
partie just pu en débattre à l'Assemblée
oui mais des amendes on y est opposé
nous-même on s'y est opposé très
fortement au Sénat il y a une opposition
de la part de la gauche à l'Assemblée
nationale qui ne voulait pas de ce texte
tout simplement nous ne voulons pas de
ce texte qui n'est pas équilibré
contrairement à ce qui a été dit par le
gouvernement donc l'assemblée nation
manifeste son rejet qu'est-ce qu'aurait
pu faire le président de la République
il aurait pu faire une deuxième lecture
il aurait pu apaiser le pays en retirant
ce texte en voyant clairement que ce
texte ne permet pas une un rassemblement
suffisamment large et de ne pas faire
adopter surtout ce texte avec l'extrême
droite entend bien mais il y a pourtant
70 % de Français qui voulaient ce ce
texte alors que dites-vous à cette
opinion alors quand vous regardez dans
les détails parce qu'il faut regarder
les détails il y a aussi 60 % des
Français qui disent ne pas connaître
précisément aussi les enjeux qui sont
liés à l'immigration ils connaissent pas
le nombre de personnes qui sont reçu
réellement chaque année quand vous
regardez plus les gens méconnaissent le
sujet et plus en fait ils y sont
favorables en quelque s oui mais bien
sûr que c'est trompeur c'est trompeur et
c'est tronqué et on verra dans
l'application ce que je ne souhaite pas
puisque je souhaite qu'il revienne
dessus et je souhaite que le Conseil
constitutionnel revienne dessus mais
dans le temps vous verrez Queen fait ça
aura des effets plus délétaires que
queautre chose et bien justement après
les enjeux politiques on va évoqué le
fond des mesures qui ont été votées
issues donc de la commission mixte
paritaire des mesures de fermeté ont été
ajoutées par la droite du Sénat qui a
revendiqué une victoire politique sur la
majorité présidentielle Flora sauvage
pour
24 contre
114 le Sénat a adopté le projet de loi
après l'accord arraché par la droite à
l'exécutif c'est un texte profondément
durci par le Sénat qui a été adopté
expulsion facilité régularisation au cas
par cas par les préfets dans les métiers
en tension fin de l'automaticité du
droit du sol le patron des sénateurs LR
se félicit des ajouts de la chambre
haute 80 % des Français pensent que il
faut maîtriser l'immigration qu'il y a
trop d'immigration en France c'est ce
qui les rassemble des Français de droite
comme des français de gauche et ce texte
là c'est un texte de fermeté alors bien
sûr il est très proche à 90 % c'est le
texte du Sénat mais là encore soyons
modestes il y avait qu'un seul texte de
toute façon face au sénateur le ministre
de l'Intérieur géralde Darmanin juge les
modifications du Sénat mineur par
rapport à son projet initial le texte du
Sénat n'est pas le texte qui remplace le
texte du Gouvernement mais qui le
complète sur 27
articles sur 27 articles un seul a été
retiré réétablissement du dél de séjour
irrégulier d'échéan de nationalité pour
les binationaux coupables domicide
volontaire sur les forces de l'ordre
débat annuel au Parlement sur les cot
migratoire pour les centristes certaines
mesures du texte étaient un mal
nécessaire je vous dis pas que tout ce
qui est voté nous convient
formidablement euh mais c'est la propre
des discussions qui permettent de
trouver des compromis sinon il y a pas
de texte votter il y a pas de majorité à
l'Assemblée nationale il faut en trouver
une en CMP et s'il y a un texte il faut
le faire adopter dans les assemblées
donc il faut que tout le monde fasse des
efforts sur la question des aides
sociales qui a fait l'objet d'un blocage
dès l'ouverture de la commission mixte
paritaire la mesure revient à une forme
de préférence nationale le bénéfice des
aides personnalisées au logement est
conditionné à 5 ans de présence sur le
territoire pour les étrangers ne
travaillant pas et à 3 mois pour les
autres enfin le Sénat a durci les
conditions du regroupement familial sur
l'aide médicale d'État qui a fait
l'objet d'apre discussion elle a été
maintenue mais le gouvernement sous la
pression des sénateurs LR qui souhaitit
la supprimer a promis de présenter une
réforme de ce dispositif début 2024 il y
a une ch certains parlaient avec le vote
de ce texte de la victoire du
rassemblement national mais au fond
est-ce que les grands gagnants ce ne
sont pas les sénateurs les républiquains
qui ont imposer leur texte durci à
Emmanuel Macron non je pense que les
sénateurs républicains se trompent ils
sont dans un puissant fond une course à
l'échalote vers l'extrême droite
également parce que ce texte c'était
déjà une reprise du programme et nous on
a dénoncé les parlementaires de gauche
au Sénat lors du débat le fait que déjà
on était dans une dérive majeure avec
une reprise du programme de l'extrême
droite donc finalement les l' ont
eux-mêmes repris les propositions de
l'extrême droite au sein du texte du
Sénat et c'est ce que nous avions
dénoncé justement d'où le fait qu'après
il vote main dans la main bien
évidemment avec l'extrême droite qui
s'est reconnu également dans son
programme alors justement on va parler
de ces mesures alors justement
l'instauration d'un délai de carence
pour le versement de certaines aides
sociales c'est ce qui figure dans le
texte alors c'est beaucoup critiqué
pourtant il existe déjà un
conditionnement par exemple la prime
d'activité est conditionné il y a un
délai de carence de 5 ans qui a été
c'est instauré d'ailleurs sur François
Hollande pour la toucher qu'est-ce qui
change quelle est la différence pour
vous bah en fait c'est c'est pas tout à
fait la la même chose déjà il y a il y a
aussi laap il y a les aides sociales
donc c'est c'est pas la même chose et là
il y a des choses qui sont social non
contributif oui non contributif et là il
y a des choses qui touchent aussi à nos
socles de solidarité on parlait tout à
l'heure de l'intégration vous pensez
qu'on intégre bien des gens quand on
leur permet pas d'accéder justement à
des aides pour qu'ell soit un minimum
qu'elle soit pas dans la pauvreté
justement qu'elle soit pas démunie
pouvoir intégrer des gens c'est pouvoir
qu'elle puisse vivre sur notre sol avec
desessens donc justement ce point que
vous évoquez est un des points
d'achopement avec le Conseil
constitution cette mesure elle ne
pourrait pas vivre avec desessence ça
veut dire qu'elle pourrait pas avoir de
logement desctenement bah
potentiellement non vous pouvez ne pas
avoir de logement de descent vous pouvez
être à la rue en plus ce texte également
l'hébergement d'urgence est également
restreint donc la problématique c'est
que les personnes sous obligation de
quitter le territoire français oui tout
à fait mais mais là ce qu'il faut voir
c'est que c'est d'ailleurs une rupture
d'égalité et à mon avis ça n'est pas pas
constitutionnel c'est un des points
d'achopement il y en a d'autres au
niveau du Conseil constitutionnel alors
il y a une autre mesure il y en a plein
qui ont été vivement discutter sur ce
texte immigration et une remise en
question endurcissement du droit du sol
avec cette loi immigration un enfant de
deux parents étrangers n'aura plus la
nationalité de manière automatique à ses
18 ans il devra faire une demande des
ses 16 ans cette fin du droit du sol ça
va changer vraiment quelque chose
concrètement parce que le la personne en
question pourra toujours faire une
demande de nationalité à 16 ans alors ce
qu'il faut faut savoir c'est que ça
aussi c'est un cavalier ce qu'on appelle
un cavalier législatif donc qui est
complètement horors sujet par rapport au
texte et qui ça je l'espère sera censuré
par le le Conseil constitutionnel mais
vous savez il y a des choses beaucoup de
personnes se disent ah bah finalement
c'est pas grand-chose mais on est dans
un état de droit à partir du moment où
vous faites des brèches vous ouvrez la
brèche c'est-à-dire qu'après d'autres
gouvernements encore moins bien
intentionnés pourront aller encore plus
loin tout à fait Marine Le Pen pourrait
aller encore plus loin puisque elle elle
est contre elle est carrément conte donc
vous ouvrez une brèche et le jour où ces
personnes voudront s'y opposer justement
quand on iront plus loin ils seront très
mal placés pour le faire parce qu'elles
auront ouvert la brèche donc c'est pour
ça que quand on est à la tête d'un état
et qu'on fait la loi il y a quand même
un minimum de responsabilité à avoir et
de vision par rapport aux valeurs qu'on
souhaite porter et là la valeur qui
souhaite porter c'est une brèche par
rapport justement au droit du sol très
clairement et pourtant Yan Chantrel
devant la représentation nationale
Gérard daranin c'est CIT d'un texte
historique qui va permettre plus de
10000 régularisations de travailleurs
sans papier dans les métiers en tension
il ment alors je vois pas sur quoi il se
base pour dire ça alors la
régularisation devrait passer par la loi
il est sûr de lui il l'a dit oui il est
sûr de lui mais à partir de moment ou
c'est quelque chose d'arbitraire qui va
être décidé par les préfets donc comment
peut-il savoir d'avance qu'il y aura
autant de bah il donnera des donnera des
consiges au préfet de régularis oui il
pe il peut donner des consignes il y en
a déjà ça s'appelle la circulaire Vals
donc je ne vois pas ce que ça ajoute à
ça
surtout c'est la loi la loi quand on est
parlementaire moi je ne souhaite pas
déléguer à l'arbitraire ce genre de Ch
c'est à nous de définir des règles
claires qui auraient permis la
régularisation pas au préfet pour qu'on
comprenne qui régularise ou pas et c'est
pas une bonne chose je suis désolé c'est
un des problèmes de notre pays aussi que
tout toutes les questions de
régularisation ou d'entrer sur notre
territoire et sous la forme de
l'arbitraire les règles ne sont pas
claires elles sont contrairement à ce
que pensent nos compatriotes c'est un
véritable parcours du combattant rien
n'est facilité justement pour les
personnes qui sont sur notre sol c'est
des fils d'attente pour des personnes
qui sont souvent sur notre territoire
depuis de très nombreuses années qui
vivent souvent des humiliations et en
fonction de certaines préfectures ont
plus de chance que d'autres je suis
désolé sur notre territoire tout le
monde devrait pouvoir accéder à des
règles simples en favorisant leur leur
intégration et pas en faisant tout pour
leur empêcher on a tout intérêt avec des
personnes qui sont dans dans notre sur
notre sol alors faciliter la vie
justement pour qu'elle puisse s'intégrer
alors Yan Chantrel dans ce texte issu de
la commission mixte paritaire il n'y a
pas eu de restriction du panier de soins
de l'aide médicale d'État pour les
étrangers en situation irrégulière
c'était une mesure de la droite
sénatoriale mais qui n'a pas été retenu
mais en échange ellisabeth bornne a
promis un texte en janvier pour réformer
l'aide médicale d'État notamment sur la
base du rapport de claudvin et Patrick
stéepanini alors qu'il ne propose pas de
toucher au panier de soin mais qui
propose par exemple qu'un étranger sous
obligation de quit le territoire
français et qui représenterait une
menace pour l'ordre public et bien n'est
pas accès à cette ame est-ce que cette
mesure en janvier vous pourriez la voter
par exemple alors en fait déjà sur la me
c'est un profond scandale parce que
c'est pas une mesure en lien en quelque
sorte d'immigration ça n c'est c'est en
lien c'est de la santé publique c'est un
c'est un dispositif de santé publique ça
n'est pas pour rien d'ailleurs que le
ministre de la Santé a démissionné parce
que lui-même étant médecin enfin venant
du monde médical c'est très bien ce qui
est en jeu derrière ça c'est un c'est
c'est un enjeu de santé publique les
microbes ils ont pas de papier je dirais
donc on a tout intérêt à soigner le plus
rapidement possible et non pas dans
l'urgence parce que ce que souhaite la
droite c'est ce qu'ils appellent une
aide médicale d'urgence c'est-à-dire de
le faire vraiment si la personne est
limite au bord de la mort et vient
encombrer les urgence mais pour
justement bien soigner les gens il faut
les prendre le plus tôt possible pour
que ça ne devient pas justement plus
coûteux et plus grave pour la personne
on a un une obligation de solidarité par
rapport au aux personnes et notre pays a
T toujours considéré moi j'ai vécu dans
d'autres pays qui n'ont pas cette
conception c'est tout à l'honneur de
notre pays que la santé c'était une un
bien universel fondamental au niveau des
droits de l'homme et de la dignité
humaine et je pense que revenir sur
cette ame c'est toucher profondément à
cette diggnité humaine et à cette cette
évidence de besoin d'aide aux plus
démunis aux personnes qui sont en
difficultés qu'elles aient des papiers
ou non alors très rapidement il y a une
mesure dans la loi aussi la déchéance de
nationalité pour les binationaux qui
tuent des policiers est-ce que cela vous
choque alors en fait c'est comme ce que
je disais tout à l'heure le problème en
général on pourrait très bien se dire ah
bah non on va pas garder voilà
exactement et et donc utiliser mais
c'est toujours la même chose à partir du
moment où vous créez une brèche vous
créez le principe de déchoir ça sera
utilisé pour d'autres choses
automatiquement il est là le danger
c'est-à-dire à partir du moment où vous
considérez dans l'État de droit moi-même
je suis binational donc vous
différenciez dans le droit français de
types de ressortissants français ceux
qui ont une autre nationalité et ceux
qui en ont qu'une déjà vous faites une
distinction au sein au sein même de la
communauté nationale quels que soient
les faits qu'ils peuvent commettre ils
doivent être condamnés punis très
sévèrement mais ce sont des
ressortissants par contre quand vous
vous faites une brèche comment pourrait
ça pourrait être utilisé ça pourrait
être utilisé plus tard pour des délites
de droit commun ça peut aller beaucoup
plus loin et il est là le danger quand
on on peut pas s'amuser à à faire les
apprentis sorciers pour soi-disant
flatter un électorat extrémiste h parce
que derrière il y a des choses beaucoup
plus graves qui pourraient advenir alors
Yanne chanrel euh la bataille des
parlementaires de gauche contre ce texte
n'est pas fini hein il souhaite une
saisine du Conseil constitutionnel euh
le les sages de la rue Cambon vont être
saisis pour bien s'exprimer sur la
constitutionnalité euh de cette loi
immigration d'ailleurs le gouvernement a
déjà dit qu'il était certain que
certaines mesures seraient retoquées euh
par ce Conseil constitutionnel euh mais
à droite au Sénat on espère encore euh
que cette loi immigration va être
épargner qu'il n'y aura pas trop de
dégâts on va écouter sur ce point la
sénatrice les républicains Murielle
joura moi je ne connais pas les
décisions du Conseil constitutionnel à
l'avance on peut aussi penser que le
Conseil constitutionnel appique le droit
et que le droit n'étant pas une sciance
exacte et d'ailleurs il l'a souvent
démontré il pourrait avoir des positions
qui évoluent dans le temps et il n'est
pas non plus interdit que le Conseil
constitutionnel se rappelle que le droit
et bien c'est aussi le reflet d'une
société aujourd'hui l'immigration est un
problème une question que se posent les
Français et peut-être que le Conseil
constitutionnel dans cette grande
plasticité qui est celle du droit va
pouvoir aussi le prendre en compte dans
sa décision qui sait Yan chentrrel selon
vous quellees mesures de cette loi
immigration peuvent être utoqué par le
Conseil constitutionnel bah il y a la
restriction du droit de sol comme je
vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure qui est
vraiment un cavalier législatif il y a
aussi la la différenciation pour l'accès
aux aides sociales qui clairement est
une rupture d'égalité aussi devant la
loi et puis il y a aussi l'histoire de
la caution aussi par rapport aux
étudiants étrangers et la remise en
cause justement du droit du sol donc
c'est un ensemble de de de paramètres
qui logiquement parce que dans ce pays
on a une constitution et qui est le
garant de cette constitution c'est le
président de la République lui-même il a
donné une interview très récemment où
lui-même finalement reconnaît aussi que
elle est problématique il n'aurait il ne
devrait pas promulguer une loi qui n'est
pas constitutionnelle alors qu'il doit
garantir justement cette
constitutionnalité donc ça aussi c'est
un c'est un vrai problème
constitutionnel que le Président de la
République çaassoit le ministre de
l'Intérieur devant les sénateurs
d'ailleurs l'a reconnu lui-même que un
une partie de ce texte ne serait pas
constitutionnel donc ça n'est pas
sérieux euh vis-à-vis de de de la
responsabilité qu'ils ont de respect de
la constitution de faire adopter des
textes que eux-mêmes savent qu'il ne
sont pas constitutionnel alors Yann
chanrel vous êtes sénateur socialiste
des des départements de gauche refusent
on dit qu'il refuserait d'appliquer la
loi et notamment les délais de carence
pour les aides sociales des étrangers
est-ce que pourtant c'est pas le rôle
des élus d'être exemplaire et de
respecter la loi je pense que dans notre
histoire je ça sera un point de
basculement cette loi vraiment je pense
que dans notre histoire il y a eu
d'autres moments malheureusement assez
sombres quand il y a des points de
basculement comme ça c'est tout à
l'honneur de certains élus de dire non
nous ne pouvons pas accepter quand il y
a des lois qui sont CZ la désobéissance
civile oui en quelque sorte ça fait
partie des démocraties aussi quand une
loi est célérate et unique effectivement
il faut dans État de droit oou la loi
s'impose à tout la désobéissence file ça
fait parti de l'État de droit aussi et
et donc il faut aussi permettre mais de
toute façon nous-même nous saisissons
nous saisissons le le Conseil
constitutionnel on n'est pas allé
jusqu'au bout il faut aller jusqu'au
bout dans le sens où il faut attendre
justement la décision du Constitutionnel
par rapport à la censure et cette loi
comme c'est pas une loi le rôle du
président de la République c'est
d'apaiser le pays c'est pas de le cliver
de le diviser je pense que cette loi
profondément on l'a vu avec les débat
que nous avons eu Clive ne n'apaise pas
donc ça serait de la responsabilité du
président de la République quelle que
soit la décision qui sera rendue par le
Conseil constitutionnel d'apaiser et de
revenir sur certaines décisions puisque
lui-même a reconnu lors d'une interview
dont la caution pour les étudiants
étrang ça n'était pas une bonne chose
d'ailleurs comment vous interprétez
cette ce double langage oui c'est un
double langage assez surprenant lui-même
reconnaî qu' qu'il a fait adopter parce
que c'est quand même le gouvernement qui
a fait adopter c'est leur texte à la
base un texte sur lequel il reconnaî que
des dispositions sont pas bonnes bah qui
reviennent dessus enfin à un moment
donné il faut alors vous dites ce texte
n'apèse pas le pays he pourtant on l'a
dit hein il y a une majorité de Français
qui actuellement était pour cette loi
immigration dans ce contexte avec un
parlement bloqué est-ce que la solution
c'est c'est pas le le le référendum
alors c'est pas possible
constitutionnellement aujourd'hui sur
l'immigration mais euh enfin voilà en ce
moment vu vu le blocage notamment au
niveau parlementaire est-ce qu'il faut
pas recourir davantage au référendum je
rappelle que vous Yan Chantrel vous avez
défendu une proposition de loi pour
utiliser de manière plus fréquente le
rip le référendum initiative partagé oui
effectivement moi je considère que le
référendum d'initiative partagé est une
bonne chose j'ai fait des propositions
on a défendu un texte qui n'a pas été
soutenu par la majorité sénatoriale qui
n' pas été adopté mais le concept c'est
justement de pouvoir donner beaucoup
plus la parole au peuple que lui-même
soit à l'initiative de débat
référendaire parce que dans des pays où
ça se passe en Suisse même en Italie ça
ça permet contrairement à ce qu'on pense
ce type de sujet n'est pas forcément à
l'ordre du jour d'ailleurs c'est le
sujet des préoccupations parce que quand
on rencontre on échange avec nos
compatriotes il nous parle pas de Lim
alorsierjet leouir d'achat c'est l'accès
à la santé c'est le logement c'est ça
réellement les problématiques de nos
compatriotes ça n'est pas l'immigration
on a bien compris on va finir parce que
vous aimez bien les questions politiques
on finit par une question politique agès
firman le Baudo a été nommé nouvelle
ministre de la Santé en remplacement
d'Aurélien Rousseau mais selon media
part elle a fait l'objet d'une enquête
judiciaire depuis 6 mois pour avoir reçu
20000 € de cadeau de la part du
laboratoire pharmaceutique Urgo pardon
est-ce que sa nomination était per comme
ministre de la Santé dans ce contexte
clairement non il reste 20 secondes non
clairement non ça n'est pas pertinent et
je pense que le Président de la
République devra en prendre acte et de
surtout lui retirer ses responsabilités
merci beaucoup Yan chanrel d'avoir été
le dernier invité de Parlement Hebdo en
2023 et merci à la Régie de nous
accompagner pour ces émissions vous
souhaite de joyeuses fêtes et à l'an
prochain ciao
[Musique]
ciao